tiny one more night nama more gonna go
crazy although time is over baby time
alright so look it's impossible to ride
tiny alright how you doing today nice to
see you
alright what's going on mr. J what we've
got here is we've got animals that you
can rent for events some of the animals
are rather expensive for example a
giraffe such as the kind of gap here you
might find anywhere from 20 to as much
as forty thousand dollars depending on
the specimen so if I wanted to buy out
your a bike and today I can buy out your
route but like a forward if you had a
private zoo you might be able to get you
might like the zebra zebras a lot less
money possibly five or six thousand
dollars fridge right here is my homie
French Montana buses French French got
monkeys in New York you keep it in the
city yeah that's gonna be fun yeah we've
got a few friends right over here to
take a look at let's do it let's do it
tidy is a nine month old giraffe now
months yeah he's a baby what's up you
smell so nice matters gas it's okay for
me leave them they're built to get their
food off of high places
what's the requirements to own the
giraffe just the money it's not the kind
of thing you can have as a pet it's
really only sort of thing you can have
for educational purposes oh okay here
we've got a couple of very exotic
hyacinth macaws these parrots are about
fifteen to twenty thousand dollars
apiece if you were to buy them and they
can live to be about eighty five years
old you like to try guarantee I got
friends doing all that still here we go
cracker
like looking at me like they always like
the highest spot fridge got that good
[ __ ] witness these parrots can say
several different words it's really a
matter of what they like to say they
like to entertain they're very
affectionate and they like to get
attention so when they want it they want
to talk to you they're gonna start
talking
we've got Ally here she's a little baby
and she just loves the tele friends is
that like your monkey saying yeah same
kind just started going through your
hair so this oh man
stop playing about 20,000 to buy this
little monkey and so we can come up here
what a hundred you so we got a monkey
footed uh we got the birds going footer
double piece put a double Pete gonna
1534 both mm-hmm so that's a 30 person
that's a 50 then we got on we got we got
a giraffe on for the photo
uh-huh then you see how to zebra for the
milk so you got a 40 plus a 45 carry the
one and you got the 55 the Honda we can
get everything from the homeless we can
get a zebra a giraffe
a monkey and two birds for ninety five
cents that's my 80 because I need about
how about Haiti so if you want to make a
80 other 15 whenever we see and we got
to get a bird of peace he already got a
mic so I get the black yeah and we got
to figure out that you're gonna split
the giraffe and the zebra and that is
that was my rap comrade French Montana
and my hippie licking ass tour guy jack
$40,000 giraffe all bluebirds high ass
rental fees when you can just buy them I
don't know not so the [ __ ] to me
but hey you decide